[Music]
welcome back to harbor unboxed
today we are taking our first look
oh god this thing is heavy at the new
geforce
rtx 3090 nvidia's latest
titan class gpu though unlike past
titans it's not actually called
titan i guess titan rtx was already
taken and
maybe rtx titan would be a little bit
confusing anyway rtx 3090 it works for
us and when compared to many of the
previous
titan class products that are actually
called titans
we feel the 3090 is a bit more
significant
it's more like the maxwell titan x in
the sense that it packs not just more
vram
but also more cores than the next
fastest geforce gpu
which in this case is the rtx 3080 so 21
more cuda cores and more than twice as
much vram with an insane
24 gigabytes of g gddr6x memory
and of course as you'd expect it does
come with a bit of a titan price tag
u.s but i suppose when compared to some
of the previous titans we've seen more
recently that's not too bad
but anyway you know what doesn't come
with a titan price tag
today's sponsored product today's video
sponsor is msi and their award-winning
b550 gaming edge wi-fi motherboard
the ultimate companion for the latest
amd ryzen processors
it comes equipped with wi-fi 6 lightning
fast pcie gen 4
2.5 gigabits per second networking and
outstanding
vrm performance this really is a board
that does it all
when paired with the 8 core 16 thread
amd verizon 7 3700x processor
you've got yourself a formidable system
for gaming content creation and
productivity
so no matter the task msi's b550
motherboards along with amd's ryzen
processors have you covered
enjoy more cores and more performance
today via the links in the video
description okay so nvidia really was
quick to point out that despite the name
this is a titan class product and of
course the implication there being
that gamers really shouldn't expect
something that's going to compete
strongly in terms of cost per frame
noting that this is a product for those
that simply want the best
it's a no compromise type product nvidia
also noted that with previous titans
they were surprised by just how much
demand there was for such a product
and they say that strong demand came
from content creators as well as gamers
seeking the ultimate performance
and no doubt those all important
bragging rights
so that really is the rtx 3090 in a
nutshell it's for those that can afford
it and
just want the best the only potential
use case where i'd say the 3090 is
really required
would be for those who can take
advantage of the massive 24 gigabyte
vram buffer
so this could be very beneficial for
those using animation and 3d modeling
tools like autodesk mayer or blender for
example
and it could also benefit video editors
working with 8k
raw footage so if you do fall into one
of those categories the rtx 3090 is
actually going to be exceptionally good
value
and at this point you've probably
already heard enough and you've raced
out to buy one
typically though here at harbor unboxed
we don't cater to professionals
so when it comes to gp reviews we're
really all about those gaming benchmarks
and today's review really won't be any
different though it will
very briefly touch on some blender
performance
but for the bulk of our audience the
interest really is in the gaming
benchmarks
and while i will still look at stuff
like cost per frame
i'm not going to weigh my conclusion as
heavily on this metric as i normally
would
as that's not what the rjx3090 is all
about
and really you don't need a review to
tell you that in terms of cost per frame
the 3090 is a bit of a terrible product
i guess spoiler alert gamers don't yet
require 24 gigabytes of vram
so asking more than twice as much for a
gpu that's only going to be at the
absolute most 20
faster well that just doesn't make sense
for those who care about value
now as usual the focus of this review
will be on the rtx 3090 as a gpu
so not nvidia's founders edition
graphics card but because this thing is
so
insane i'll give you a few quick stats
it measures
313 millimeters long stands 124
millimeters tall
and is 52 millimeters thick so it is a
bit of a beast in terms of dimensions
and as you've probably guessed it does
take up three expansion slots
but the most impressive stat is the
weight this thing tips the scales at two
thousand
one hundred and twenty five grams making
it the heaviest graphics card i've ever
seen
now pushing and pulling air through this
maze of heatsinks are two 110 millimeter
fans
and like the rtx 3080 fe model airs
exhausted out all over the place
and we'll look at the thermal
performance a little later on the review
then around at the i o panel we get the
same configuration as the 3080 model
so there's a single hdmi 2.1 port and
three display port 1.4 a outputs it is a
seriously impressive graphics card and
the best design nvidia has produced by a
country mile
now before we jump into the benchmarks
here's a quick side-by-side
specifications comparison
with the rtx 3080 and 2080ti
it is worth noting that both gpus are
based on the same ga 102 die
the 3080 is just a cut down version as
mentioned earlier the 3090 packs 21
more cruder cores as well as 21 more
texture mapping units but just
17 more render output units or rops
in terms of core clock speeds both are
very similar but the 3090 does receive
slightly faster gddr6x memory
hitting 19.5 gigabits per second and
when paired with the 384 bit wide memory
bus is good for
935.8 gigabytes per second
of memory bandwidth so a 23 increase
over the 30 80.
based on those figures you'd probably
expect that at most
the 30 90 will be around 17 percent
faster than the 38 in games
but due to the way these architectures
typically scale in most games
the gains are probably going to be quite
a bit lower
and that means the 30 90 is going to be
a very small
increase over the rtx 3080 now for
testing we're using our ryzen 9 3950x
test system
featuring four sticks of low latency
ddr4 3200 memory
operating in a dual channel dual rank
configuration and of course the focus
will be on the 4k
results but it'll also be including the
1440p data
as well starting with death stranding we
see that the 1440p
results are very underwhelming
though we could be a little bit cpu
limited here either way it means for a
lot of gamers the gains at 1440p in this
title are going to be
very very small even when increasing the
resolution of 4k which sees the gpu
become
the primary system bottleneck the 3090
is just six percent faster than the 3080
taking the average frame rate from 107
fps to 113 fps
i really wasn't expecting much from the
3090 but i've got to say this
is a very disappointing result
next up we have horizon zero dawn and
here we're again looking at very weak
performance gains at 1440p
just a seven percent improvement here
over the rtx 3080
then as we move to the 4k resolution
it's worth noting that the only
performance limiting component here
is the graphics card and despite that
the 3090 is just
8 faster than the 3080 taking the
average frame rate from 73 fps to
79 fps that said we do see a much
healthier 18
boost to the 1 low performance but even
here
that's pretty underwhelming rainbow six
siege sees a 10
boost at 1440p as here we went from 327
fps with the rtx 3080
to 360 fps with a 3090
so not amazing but it is at least a
double-digit gain
the 4k results are a little more
impressive here we're looking at a 15
performance uplift and spoiler alert
this is about the biggest margin we saw
in the 14 game sample so that being the
case i'm not going to bother going over
the other 11 games that we have
it's pretty boring and very repetitive
stuff
that being the case let's just hit pause
or rather cancel on the individual game
graphs and we'll just jump into the 14
game averages for the 1080p
1440p and 4k data then of course we'll
check out stuff like power consumption
cost per frame and we'll also take a
look at the margins seen in individual
titles
oh and we'll also take a quick look at
some blender render performance
before wrapping this thing up starting
with the 1080p data
here we're looking at a 5 performance
uplift over the 30 80
and a 21 increase over the 2080 ti and
really they are the only two relevant
gpus for comparison
then at 1440p the margin over the 3080
grew to eight percent and the margin
over the 2080 ti grew to 32
so spending 114 more on the rtx 3090 is
gonna be a pretty tough sell for an
eight percent increase at 1440p
but then who am i kidding those with
deep pockets won't hesitate for a moment
to snap them up
at that price to performance ratio
finally for those gaming at 4k
the rtx 3090 offered on average 11 more
performance over the 3080
and if you're coming from an rtx 2080 ti
that's a decent 45
increase for a 25 increase in price
now in terms of power consumption the
rtx 3090 didn't consume
that much more power than the rtx 3080
at least when measuring the entire
system consumption from the wall
here we're still shy of 600 watts so a
decent 750 watt unit will have you more
than covered
at least prior to any overclocking using
the nvidia pcat tool we see that the
3090 consumed just six percent more
power than the 3080
which is very surprising though it was
only 11 faster in this test
still not a bad result and it explains
why the rtx 3090 fe card runs so cool
which we'll look at in a moment but
first here's a look at
performance per watt based on the
figures we just saw the rtx 3090 is
actually better than the 3080 in terms
of performance per watt
and no doubt this is due to a bidding
process that sees the best silicon
reserved for the 3090
still in terms of efficiency the 3090 is
surprisingly good
the cool thing about the massive rtx
3090 founders edition graphics card
is the cool operating temperatures well
that and the fact that it is virtually
silent
after an hour of gaming the fans spun at
just over 1000 rpm
where they were quieter than the other
fans in our test system
and therefore the graphics card couldn't
be heard despite the low operating
volume the gpu peaked at just 66 degrees
which is
again very impressive and here it
maintained an average clock speed of
1830 megahertz
so very impressive stuff but also not
terribly surprising
given how absolutely massive the
founders edition 3090 is
here's a look at the cost per frame data
which again isn't something those
typically interested in a product like
the rtx 3090 really care about
but we have the data anyway so why not
share it
no surprises here the rtx 3090 is a
terrible value proposition for gamers
but it's also very amusing to me to see
that despite costing
1500 u.s it's still actually better
value than the rtx 2080
ti and by a reasonable margin as well
in fact at the 4k resolution the rtx 39
is considerably better value than the
rtx 2080 ti
and it's really not that much worse than
parts released last year like the radeon
7 for example
it's also crazy to see that in modern
games it's really not that much worse
than something like the gtx 1080
a gpu that was actually class leading
for its time
since i did skip over looking at the
frame rates in all 14 games here's a
look at the percentage gains offered by
the 3090 over the 30 80 in
all titles tested starting with the
1440p
data as you can see at best it was 16
faster seen in world war z but typically
we're looking at high
single digit gains now at 4k we're not
cpu limited in any of the games
and a 5.3 gigahertz 10 700k for example
provides the exact same frame rates in
all titles tested with the rtx 3090
again the 3090 was just 10 percent
faster on average
with the biggest margin once again seen
at world war z
where the 3090 was just 18 faster
now for those of you hoping to upgrade
from a 2080 ti you're at most going to
see around a 44
performance improvement which is what we
saw in resident evil 3.
typically though you are looking at more
like a 30 performance uplift which is
about what the 2080 ti offered over the
1080 ti
for a 70 increase in price so from that
perspective
the 30 90 is kind of great value and
here we see that the margins are even
better at 4k
and now the 3090 is up to 58 faster than
2080 ti
and this time that scene when testing
with world war z though
it is worth noting that you will see
margins as low as 34
in games like gears 5. since we don't
test productivity performance of gpus
and any of our gpu reviews
i went and quickly tested a few gpus in
blender
here we can see that the radeon 7 was
comparable to the rtx 2080 ti in this
application and that made it a pretty
great value option
though it also wasn't much faster than
the vanilla 2080.
anyway the 3080 was a little over twice
as fast as the radeon 7 in this test
boosting performance by 108 percent or
if you go the other way it reduced the
render time by 52
again we see that the rtx 3090 was just
faster than the 3080 so that's in line
with our best case gaming performance
margin
and this means unless your workload
requires more than 10 gigabytes of vram
you're just much better off with the rtx
3080 in terms of value
so as i said earlier it's a pretty
simple equation for those running
productivity tasks
if your workload requires a lot more
than 10 gigabytes of vram
the 3090 will be a godsend if not
it's kind of pointless and it's just
something you'd buy because i
guess you can so that's the geforce rtx
3090. it's not
it's not terribly exciting i guess
certainly not as exciting as last week's
rtx 3080 release
but as soon as jensen said this was a
titan class product i really did know
what we're in for
if you're a gamer this release is very
boring in my opinion
and very pointless even if we did see
the 20
performance boost that many had
predicted that would have been still
pretty weak given the price
but it would have been certainly more
interesting than what we ended up with
in short the rtx 3090 makes no sense for
gamers
it's really that simple the massive 24
gigabyte vram buffer has
no appeal here and despite nvidia's best
efforts 8k
gaming just it's not really a thing hell
4k gaming is still pretty niche
that said i did try out 8k gaming and it
was quite impressive seeing
60 fps and do maternal at this extremely
extreme resolution it was also possible
to average 60 fps in control
with the help of dlss rendering at its
lowest possible resolution of 1440p so
not really 8k gaming then and without
dlss control ran
at 5 fps it is a little bit sketchy
claiming 8k
gaming performance given that for the
most part you will require dlss support
for it to happen that said do maternal
did work very well without dlss because
of course the game doesn't support it
it looked great and we saw vram usage
hit 16 gigabytes and that's actual usage
not just allocation anyway i seriously
doubt too many gamers are keen for that
sweet 60 hertz experience
at 8k and on that note we do know that
most of you are now targeting 1440p
144hz because we've run some polls in
the past and that was by far the most
popular choice
for people either having just upgraded
or wanting to upgrade
so that being the case it is quite
disappointing to see that the rtx 3090
has little to offer
over the 3080 here and it's also true
when using a heavily overclocked intel
processor
but as i've already said now gaming is
kind of a waste with the 30 90.
you just do it because you can and the
same is also true for productivity tasks
unless you can utilize that extra vram
the 3090 doesn't really make sense over
the 3080
but as i've said numerous times now if
you do require 24 gigabytes of vram or
certainly much more than 10 gigabytes of
vram
the rtx 3090 will be well pretty awesome
previously you were looking at having to
spend more like two and a half thousand
dollars us on the titan rtx for that
sort of memory capacity
and that means you're now getting the
bigger memory buffer with a much faster
gpu
at a much lower price so a bit of a
win-win there
other than that nvidia's found edition
model is super impressive it's also
well it's super massive and super heavy
that's part of what makes it very
impressive
and this is probably going to be i
shouldn't call it right now because i
haven't tested any
aib cards yet but at the very least
given the thermals we've seen all that
sort of stuff this is
certainly going to be one of the best
1390 graphics cards but we will be
looking at the asus strix and the msi
a gaming extra very shortly on the
channel so make sure you stay tuned for
that
and as for this review i think that is
going to do it for this one so
i'll wrap it up here let me know what
you thought about the rtx 3090 in the
comment section below
was it disappointing was it pretty much
what you thought it would be especially
after jensen sort of said it was a titan
class probably
let me know in the comment section below
if you like the video you know what to
do if you'd like to uh
check out the patreon stuff we will have
a live stream
on monday so that's coming up next week
early next week
there will be a live stream for patreon
members so you can tune in and watch
that if you are a patreon member
you'll also get access to our exclusive
discord chat where you can
talk with two of myself behind the
scenes videos where we talk about all
kinds of things
behind the scenes type things and q a's
anyway if you're interested link is in
the video description
if not that is fine and i would like to
just thank you for watching this review
i'm your host steve and i will see you
again next time
10 11
12 13
14.
[Music]
you